fueled by fear and grim determination
the people of Mosul make their escape
on city streets and thoroughfares and
mud-soaked tracks why did you decide to
leave your home they take what they can
carry and leave the ones they loved
behind Oliver Oliver but he's not Indian
the exodus takes shape up at Baghdad
junction on the outskirts of town where
10 12 even 14,000 people board buses for
their refugee camps every day the men in
charge are struggling while the evacuees
are afraid of being left behind the
Iraqi army half a dozen buses at the
moment but that is simply not enough
thousands of people they are hungry
they're tired they're covered in mud and
they're frightened they want to get out
of here there's not room for everybody
we spoke to one woman who have been
fighting for a seat not everyone makes
it to the junction at a nearby clinic
medics help residents who've been hurt
while trying to escape
this man shot in the head by an Isis
sniper others were hit by grenades
it's a typical afternoon said stuff city
residents who survived are dropped off
here at a waterlogged reception center
in imam al aliy Oh 200,000 have been
taken to this town
the men are screened by intelligence
officers while the women try to find a
place to stay
but the town's refugee camp is full and
its occupants say they haven't got
enough to eat and on several occasions
during our visit we saw refugees and
town residents fighting for food water
and blankets the threat of gunfire and a
policeman stick did little to help
people kept driving at the truck until
everything was taken away Tom Harlem the
man in charge of the Moulton Agency
resettlement effort this general Bassam
Alta and he took us for a tour of the
facilities although it was soon clear
there were some coordination issues to
sort out my little municipal yet not to
mention a shortage of basic supplies in
the kitchen the general was told there
was no gas or ingredients to cook with
but his biggest problem is lack of space
in the camps and the general blames the
UN
and Billy you are normal today
sorry an astronomer Teleco big man in
Mohammed he says more tents will be
provided but that's little comfort to
the Abdullah's whose son has cerebral
palsy they can't find a place to stay
calm okay my best name in the German
Navy was the resettlement of residents
is as important as the battle for Mosul
itself for there is despair and growing
instability here John sparks Sky News in
Mosul